bringing ideas so I'm going to talk
about something different from the
official privacy which is our search
privacy and our project is called
pufferfish privacy mechanisms for
correlated data and this won't work with
usual and come and catch a train from UC
San Diego so in many machine learning
tasks with the OS sensitive data that is
also correlated for example who may want
to learn from social network they had a
spreading pattern of flu or was a month
older from persons activity checking
they had the amount of exercise this
person come back there during a week so
in this case the correlation among the
data I can make privacy protection
harder and let's see why so let's look
at a small example so here suppose we
have some some social network and the
full status of each person in it and
suppose now we want to publish
approximately the number of people with
flu and at the same time we don't want
any adversary to know whether a
particular person is you or not so
suppose now I am anniversary trying to
you further flu status of this
particular person if I know this person
belong to this group of people were
about eighty percent of the people they
are affected and suppose I know flu is
highly contagious then I can say this
person is also affected with high
confidence so essentially the
correlation among the data help me
transfer my general knowledge about the
social network to sub civic knowledge
about this particular person and this is
how correlation among the data can make
privacy protection harder and now let's
look at what the social privacy will do
in this case
so because the basic idea of
differential privacy is to hide the
effect of single individual in the state
has said so what is going to do is to
add La Paz nodes of scale parameter 1
over epsilon to the actual number of
affected people as we have mentioned if
everyone's full status are independent
of each other than this
of Lewis maybe enough than this amount
of noise is enough to guarantee privacy
however we all know that people say
instead as are correlated with each
other so in this case when we have a
large connected group and wealth who is
helic very contagious then the this
amount of noise may not be enough to
guarantee privacy so is that we may use
something called differential privacy
where the idea is to hide the effect of
a group of people so instead of well
over epsilon we may want to add the
customers of scale G over epsilon where
G is the largest group size so this
amount of noise is enough to guarantee
privacy either with correlation but
notice that adding such huge amount of
noise like it intuitive intuitively it
means we are assuming everywhere in the
same group their food Status are
completely correlated with each other
meaning they are either out healthy or
out real which is of course not true in
practice and when the group size is very
large I think this amount of noise may
completely destroy our utility so in
between differential privacy which is
enough to protect privacy for
independent data but may not be enough
for correlated data and group
differential privacy which take a very
conservative view by treating everyone
as if they are completely correlated and
thus give make it not enough utility can
we have something in between
so when observation is that in most of
the real applications though we have a
certain amount of correlation among data
the average amount of correlation is not
actually very high so if we are able to
capture this actual amount of
correlation we may be able to get a
better privacy utility trade-off and
this motivates the proposal for
population privacy which is a framework
with correlation taken into
consideration and now let's look at how
this that
work so to define powerful privacy first
we need to specify three components the
first is secret as which is a site of
secret we want to protect for example we
want to protect Alice has flu and we
want to protect Bob was sleeping at
10:00 a.m. a second we have secrets that
cube which is a set of pairs of secret
we want to be indistinguishable for
example we don't want at nursery to know
whether Alice has flu or she's she's
healthy or we don't want anniversary to
know whether Bob was sleeping or
exercising at 10 a.m. and lastly we have
this capital theta which is a site of
distribution that possibly generate our
dataset for example we may assume flu is
passed with a certain probability or Bob
live with a certain living style so this
theta is basically where the data
correlation is captured and every
distribution in theta represents one
adversary's
belief about how our data is generated
and we are going to protect against all
the adversary who's believed the
scientist at introversion set capital
theta and now we can define epsilon
puffer fish privacy so we say a
mechanism an is epsilon puffer fish
private under the under the three
parameters as the secret q the secret
Paris athlete had a set of distributions
if for all W in the range of I'm and for
all seek repair Si and SJ our secret
pair set and for our distribution small
theta
our distributions that capital theta so
let's say we use X to denote a random
variable which represent our data set so
it's a random variable tall from the
distribution theta what we want is the
probability of an X equal to W given
theta and as I over the same thing given
theta and SJ to be upper bounded by e to
the
so long so let's if there's two are the
PDF for the to distribute for the two
distributions then what we want is that
for Amitabh you under support the ratio
between those two parts to be upper
bounded by e to the absolute so this is
a so this is pretty close to the
definition of differential privacy like
absolute here quantify the privacy laws
and smaller absolute means we have been
her privacy but notice the difference
here is that the probability is taken
not only with respect to the randomness
of the algorithm but it's also with
respect to the randomness of the data so
the advantage of pufferfish privacy is
that first is allows us to capture
correlation and second it was showing in
the original paper that this definition
is actually at organization for a
differential privacy so when the
distributions that contain all the
independent distribution for data
powerful fish privacy essentially reduce
to differential privacy so the next
question we would ask is how can we
achieve high proficiency so there are
some prior work on algorithm for a
special population instantiation for
example the Blowfish privacy so in our
work we proposed two mechanisms the
first is called the west's and magnesium
which is completely general working for
any puffer fish framework and the second
is more efficient algorithm called the
mark of quote mechanism which worked for
the case when theta correlation is
captured by Bayesian network and i also
like to mention there was a concurrent
work and we are going to compare with
this in our experimental in our
experimental part so now as we have
covered the definition for proper fish
privacy and i'm going to talk about the
two algorithms we proposed in our paper
the first is the wisest type mechanism
so remember to guarantee differential
privacy we earlier would like to add
some random noise to the truth
result and similar to the algorithm for
differential privacy we also would like
to add some random noise and we would
and we need this noise to be enough to
make the secret pairs indistinguishable
and there any distribution or a
distribution set so recall that for
differential privacy in the Laplace
mechanism if we are given inaccurate
function f we're going to add the cosmos
which is proportional to the global
sensitivity of F and the ghost global
sensitivity basically measure how
sensitive the function f is with respect
to the change of the data set and
similarly in our case we would like to
ask how sensitive F is with respect to
the secret the secret pair meaning when
we replace secret as a secret as J how
much the function f can change but
different from differential privacy here
the function value the function the
function value F is it's not a fixed
value but it's rather a random variable
so what we're going to come here is the
probability distribution of F given
theta as a versus the probability
distribution given theta and as J so
essentially we need the right distance
measurement for these two distributions
and in our paper we find that the right
distribution the right distance
measurement to use as the infinity was a
sentence let's look at the definition so
given two random variable action-y is
following distribution new and new let's
say gamma mu nu is the side of our
possible joint distribution of x and y
and then for any drug distribution in
this said let as let's say is gamma so
we let as small gamma to be the support
of this joint distribution so first for
any of this joint distribution we're
going to look at other XY pair in the in
the support of this district
look at the max difference between
accent 1
then we numerator out of hospital and
distribution our said and take her you
frame so iteratively this quantity
matters the minimum effort we need to
convert distribution mill to
distribution view so for example if we
have this two discrete distribution and
support one two three four we are going
we would like to do something to convert
mewtwo new so for example we can do
something like this first we move the
probability mass at position one of MU
to position one and two of new and then
we move the probability mass of people
at position 2 to position two of new and
similarly for the probability mass at
position three and four we can do
something similar so notice that in this
when we do when we do this when we do
this commercial we basically the the
maximum amount of distance we move as
one
so in this case the new frontier was the
distance between mu and nu is going to
be one and now let's look at how we can
use this to variation distance it's
summing over the values now it's not
like so we are trying to match like
convert the distributions not not
marrying that the different speech if
you if you put them like one against the
other you just need to move it's a
difference pair each one know
the satellites which are very close
distribution very easily oh sorry yeah
like how far I want to know so the way
we constructed this algorithm is like
this so given an incorrect functional I
for analytic repair as I am astray and
for any distribution theta in our
capital R theta we let em U as it'll be
the probability distribution for F given
theta and as I and mutated happy the
distribution of F given theta and SJ
then we compute the infinity of resonant
distance which mu I theta and nu J theta
and after enumeration throughout the
parish and other distributions we are
going in to take supima among all this
infinity was a distance and let's say
this value is w we would like to add a
personalized of scale that bill over
absolute to the two result of our query
so we can show that this algorithm
guarantee epsilon puffer fish privacy
and one thing I think worth mentioning
is that when the when the paraffins
privacy reduce to differential privacy
when the set containing all the
independent they'd had distribution the
W value here is exactly equal to the
global sensitivity of the career
function so basically we can view what
is the mechanism as analog to the Past
mechanism for a differential privacy so
how does the utility compare to group
differential privacy let's look at a
small example so how so for example here
we have some newer now some social
network it can pay for which contain
four people and we know the flu status
of each person in this social network we
would like to publish roughly the number
of people with flu and suppose at this
moment we only try to protect the
privacy for this orange person and let's
say the distribution of the total
of affected people given the status of
this person is rating in this table so
if we calculate the infant he was in a
distance between the two distribution we
can see that the distance yes - so the
Westerner mechanism are going into ad la
Paz noise of scale parameter - over
absolute - the shoe count on the other
hand for group differential privacy is
going into at La Paz noise for our
absolute because there are in total four
people in this social network and this
is not only true for this small example
in fact we can show that that was the
mechanism is always at least as good as
the global sort of group differential
privacy the cosmic needs are before the
group the official Travis sorry just a
clerk can clarify what's the definition
of X of I here so we have two
probability distributions over the
numbers of effective people yeah and so
what are we conditioning on so that is
the status of the orange person that is
the person we try to protect you this
case
okay so we're conditioning on knowledge
of whether this person is a or healthy
yeah but you may notice that there might
be some computation in show for this was
in the mechanism so one drawback hope is
that it can be computationally expensive
especially when there are infinitely
many distributions and seek repairs to
enumerate - and when the two
distributions we need to compare given
here was a distance on are you regular
so to build a more efficient algorithm
we look at a more special case
tape a distribution which yes the
patient network so here we look at
subsurface specifically data that are
generated from Bayesian network and we
assume the secret we're trying to
protect is the value of every node in
this patient
and the secret pair is whether the note
is taking value a versus taking value P
so this algorithm is called the Markov
quote mechanism or MQM which I'm going
to cover next
so I will straight houses and QR
algorithm work on the special case
Bayesian network that the Markov chain
so here our distribution set consists of
Markov chain of length and so the notice
x1 to xn and each lie in some state
space 1 to k we may potentially have a
lot of different Markov chains of the
different transition matrices included
in theta and the secret we are trying to
protect is the value of any X I and the
secret pair is either the X is taking
values versus taking value T for any SD
pair and for our X here we further
assume our career function is one liches
for example the counting coverage and
this assumption can easily be extended
to any DHS function the intuition of a
neuron comes from observing the property
of a Markov chain so suppose we have
this Markov chain and at this moment we
only try to protect the privacy for this
black node X so as we have mentioned
before because there are some
correlations in this Markov chain to
protect X I it is not only enough to
hide the potential information leak from
X I itself but we also need to hide the
information leaked from our other node
because they are correlated but notice
that as we go further and further away
from X I to the two ends of the chain
the correlation there become weaker so
if we go further enough we can
essentially find a set of known which
are almost independent to X i we call
them X are our four remote and
correspondingly we have a set of
neighbor node which are closer to excite
we call them actually
for a neighbor so this side of note may
be more highly correlated with access
and in between we have these two nodes
as separation between the remote and
neighbor we call them execute so because
the the correlation between X I and X
neighbor actually mode they are of
different level we are going to try to
hide the potential information leak in
those two S's using two different ways
so for x remote what we're going to do
is to use a small correction factor to
hide the potential information leak and
for the neighbor node we are going into
a cake a conservative will by treating
them as if they're completely correlated
with X I just similar to group
differential privacy so two from two to
convert this intuition to a formal
algorithm
there are basically three questions we
need to answer the first is how do we
how do we formalize the separation
between the neighbor and the remote set
and second is what is the small
correction factor we are going to use
for extra mode and lastly what should we
do for an X neighbor so I'm going to
answer them one by one
so first we formalize the separation by
different and by exploiting the
structure of the Markov chain so we
define some notion called the Markov
quote so for a set of node XQ we say it
is a mark of code for X I Y first
deleting X cubed break the chain into
two parts X remote and X neighbor where
X is contained in X later a second given
X Q X I and X remote they are
independent of each other so in this
case for this X i if we take take this
to note as our mark of quote then we can
see that a brick harbor changing to this
free and blue parts corresponding to a
neighbor and remote node and also we can
see that if we are given execute an X
and remote they are independent of each
other a second let's look at the small
correction factor so here we find that a
ret notion to use is something we
defined as the maximum force so for X I
and any set of node X a we define the
maximum fluency in this formula so
basically it is the ratio the log of the
ratio of the probability as a equal to a
certain value given X is equal to us and
distribution theta over the probability
of X is equal to the same value given X
I equal to T and distribution data we
are going to take a maximum among our St
pair and all the distribution and our
possible value for X a so essentially it
does this max influence capture how much
X I and X either correlated with each
other and a smaller value means they are
less correlated in the case where they
are completely independent this value is
going to be 0 so we find that the small
correction factor we want to use for a
remote so here we actually do it for the
union of the remote and the mark of
quote we find that the small correction
factor we should use is the max
influence which in the between X I and
the union of remote and mark of course
as we have mentioned before given the
mark of course X I and X remote they are
independent of each other so this
further you go to the max influence each
X I and execute so lastly let's look at
what we should do for the set of
neighbor node so here we just do
something pretty something the same as
the group diff when we do what we do for
a group differential privacy by treating
them as if they are completely they are
going to change completely together with
X I so since we assumed our function is
1 Lipsius when all of them change
together the function value can change
by at most the number of node in
labor set so putting everything together
this is the scale of the noise we're
going to I where the numerator is the
number of neighbor node and the
denominator is absolute - the max
influence between X I and execute notice
that this quantity can be computed for
any given Markov code and in practice
there are many different Markov codes we
can use so and they can lead to a
trade-off between the numerator and the
denominator for example if we use a
markup quote which is further away from
excite and the numerator will grow
because we will have more neighbor node
on the other hand the denominator can
also grow because the max influence
between X I and xq are going to be
smaller so in practice what we do is we
only will try to enumerate through a
bunch of valid Markov code and use the
one that required the minimal amount of
noise so to protect the privacy for any
note in our Markov chain we are going to
repeat this process for our of them and
taking the maximum which is enough to
guarantee privacy for any of them I
think that Haase Lewis proportional to
this maximum value so we can prove that
this algorithm guarantee epsilon power -
privacy and in terms of efficiency and
now you know you implementation on
Markov chain will have capacity and to
that you wear and is the dance of the
chain so we can show we also want to
compare this with the result we can get
for we can get from global differential
privacy and we can easily show that this
is as at least as good as global
differential privacy because because one
trivial mark of quote yes empty set so
in this case the neighbor not contain
all the node you know
or Markov chain and we're going to add
noise exactly the same as what we do for
a global differential privacy but in
practice yearly are the noise we add is
not going in to scale with the length of
the chain so when the chain grows the
advantage of our algorithm is more
significant compared to global
differential privacy now I'm going to
show some experimental results which
demonstrate the privacy utility
trade-off for our Markov quote mechanism
the experiments are done for some real
and synthetic Markov chain of different
lengths and different state space and
the secret we're trying to protect is
the value of each node and the Curie
function here we consider is the
histogram over the states so there are
four algorithms we are going to come
here
the first is good differential privacy
as a baseline and the second is the
concurrent work we just mentioned and we
have two versions of MQM I'm human or
browse and MQM exact so um approach we
use a weighted sum approximation for the
max influenced computation in order to
make the algorithm more efficient and
I'm - I'm exact compute the exact max
influence and is surely has higher
utility at the cost of longer running
time the first date how we used is some
synthetic Markov chain so here we
consider a bender in Markov chain so the
state is basically 0 or 1 and the lens
is a hundred we generates the change in
this follow your way so suppose suppose
we use p0 and p1 to denote the
transition probability from 0 to 0 and 1
to 1 so the diagonal and the diagonal
entry of our transition matrix and then
for any value L which is smaller than
point point 5 we defined theta out to be
the set or the set of transition matrix
corresponds with the distributions who
stand
lying in the wrench out your one - ow
so basically when I'll become larger
this set will have smaller sets we look
at epsilon equal to 1 and epsilon equal
to 5 in this case and here is the result
so the x-axis is our value and as we
have mentioned for larger out dr. L
means the distribution set has a smaller
size and the y axis is the Elven arrow
of our estimated frequency versus the
true frequency so here the yellow line
is GK 17 and the blue green lines are
the two versions of our MQM I didn't
post the result for group differential
privacy because it was very that in this
case so we can see that for all the
algorithm if we difference out and their
utility will become better which is to
be expected and we can also see that our
two versions of MQM works you know well
the range of distributions that compared
to gk7 see I notice that of this gray
line here yes the green line here is
basically the threshold which for the GK
7gk 17 am with them to work so basically
on the left hand side here chicken 70
will will completely fail but we have
also observed that like even when we get
closer to the screen line noise added by
ticket 17 is super large compared to our
algorithm and the SEC yep this is the
error in your histogram query
oh oh sorry I should I should have
mentioned so because we are doing your
banner a chain or that histogram is
accounting so we are just recording the
oh that accounts for the difference
between their to counter and the
estimate haircut
so the second set of experiment we ran
is on some real-life Markov chain which
is we got from some physical activity
tracking data so here we have activity
tracking happen on three groups of
people the first is some overweight head
subject and second is some other subject
and there is some cyclist their tracking
happens around average of second for
roughly seven days during day time
resulting in roughly three trains each
of Lance 3000 for every subject and
there are four stays active standing
still standing moving sendin Terry we
are going to compute the histogram over
this the again the secret we're trying
to protect is the activity performed at
every moment for every subject so so
here we just assume we know the
distribution and we obtain that
distribution from the central data I'm
going to show one aggregate histogram
for each group whole subject here are
the three histograms the gray bar here
are the true frequency and the results
here are twenty rounds of group
differential privacy of the blue green
dots are twenty rounds of the two
version of our algorithm so I want to
mention that here GK 17 doesn't really
apply because their algorithm requires
some condition on the transition matrix
which is not satisfied in the state
hasn't so comparing group differential
privacy and two versions of nqm we can
see that in general of our over MQM does
much better than group differential
privacy so quantitatively the noise is
roughly ten times away from each other
and we can also see that the noise we
add is pretty small compared to their
true signal so basically after adding
the noise we can still see different
patterns across different groups like
for example some like the cyclist
more active compared to the other tools
the last side of experiment we done is
um some electricity power meter reading
they'd have so this is from a single
household in in Canada and the mental
reading happens and around every one
minute four in total two years resulting
you one chain of events about Amelia and
we here divide the power level into 50
Wednesday's the secret we're trying to
protect is the power level at any given
time so again the distribution is
obtained from the data and here is the
result so here I didn't plot group
differential privacy because the result
is very bad in this case because the the
length of the chain is very large and
again GK Simonton doesn't really apply
because the Commission is again so we
can see that the two versions of an
helium work pretty well on this dataset
and but for the tail part we can see
roughly that I'm sure I'm exact perform
better than and QM or house so comparing
this to our them in terms of running
time we can see that I'm QM exact is
refer in general will take much longer
hand and km across
especially when the state space is very
large so in practice we would suggest
using IBM across when the state space is
large and when there are enough data to
mitigate the effect of the approximation
so so like in the case for the parameter
additionally I also would like to
mention the composition property of MQM
because composition is very important in
practice and we all know that
differential privacy can compost very
well but it was showing you the orange
note paper that in general pervez
privacy does not compose so what we want
to do is to look at a special case where
the algorithm we use to guarantee
parentage privacy is nqm and when the
data comes from Markov chain so in this
case we like to show some composition
results we heard that there are two
types of compositions parallel and
sequential in parallel composition we
run two algorithm each guarantee
epsilon1 epsilon2
privacy and then we test two algorithm
they ran on disjoint subsets of the data
and for a sequential composition we have
two algorithm which run on the same data
set for a differential privacy in the
first case where we will have max at
some epsilon two as our total privacy
laws and in the second case we are going
to have absolute 1 plus absolute - so
now let's look at how i'm qm can
guarantee for us Markov chain so first
for a parallel composition we assume
that the we have two versions of m qm
running on two disjoint subsets of one
markov chain so the difficulty of
transition here comes from the
correlation between the two sub chain so
basically if we publish some statistic
on the first sub chain then this will
also review information on the second
sub chain due to correlation but we have
shown that if we use m qm to do the two
release then if the two chains they are
long enough and their distance are also
there are also far away from each other
then this whole release will guarantee
max
epsilon1 epsilon2 puffer fish
so which matches the result for official
privacy and then let's look at
sequential composition so so here again
the correlation can cause us trouble
because of the correlation once we
publish some statistic and the Markov
chain then this published the result may
give us much more information on the
chain gang in the case when data are
independent of each other so in fact we
can show some negative result that if we
went to algorithm and one and M two
which are not massive called mechanism
but more general purposes more general
rhythm that satisfy pufferfish privacy
if there's two algorithms guarantee
epsilon1 epsilon2 pufferfish privacy
then the whole process may not guarantee
absolute 1 plus absolute to a proper
fish privacy however we show that if the
two release are done using MQM then this
whole process can always guarantee
absolute 1 plus absolute imperative
privacy which also matches the result
for official policy so we believe this
composition properties can make mqi more
useful and more attractive real
applications so as a summary i have
talked about the two algorithm we
proposed the first is called the vs a
mechanism which is the first general
algorithm for pufferfish privacy and the
second i talked about the mark of course
mechanism including the mark of crota
max influence we defined to capture the
property of Markov chain and i also
showed some experimental result on
synthetic real life markov chain and
also shows the composition property of
MQM which matches the result for
differential
yep this
[Applause]
so you know you've represented results
first or first order Markov chains but
is it just sort of extends pretty
straightforwardly to condition it's
still work for here yeah so so basically
in all our definition for Mexico's they
are not restricted to marketing so we
can still like they can still work for a
general vision what about the
composition the the composition is a bit
harder for general patient that but I
believe for the sequential composition
we can show that so basically for
composition to work what we want is what
we hope is that how the other algorithms
they are using the same Markov quote so
if we can guarantee this then we can see
repose or you know you know like if we
want to relax the results a little bit
for patient Network what we can say is
that the whole process guarantee K times
the max among all the individual
guarantee
either
well thank you very much
[Applause]